quantum entanglement allows particles to be linked regardless of the space between them this is so counterintuitive
that even Einstein didn't think it was true in today's episode of kissk in the classroom we'll talk about how Bell's
theorem proved Einstein
wrong welcome to kuit in the classroom in this series we'll use kkit to explore some fundamental concepts commonly
covered in Quantum Computing related courses each video will also be accompanied by an interactive module
Linked In the description below so be sure to check that out in the quantum coins video we discussed how measuring a
Quantum superposition is an inherently probabilistic process like flipping a coin in some ways but how do we know
this could it be that a Quantum particle secretly hides a predetermined outcome of a measurement but we somehow fail to
capture this information in our theory in the early days of quantum mechanics this question was the subject
of heated debate with two main factions in one Camp was Einstein who believed that quantum mechanics was incomplete
that is that it was missing some variables that were necessary to fully describe a system Einstein thought that
these so-called hidden variables if found would resolve some of the seemingly paradoxical and probabilistic
aspects of quantum mechanics in the other Camp was Max Bourne Bourne argued
that the probabilistic description given by quantum mechanics is all that is specified by nature in other words it
isn't just that we don't know the state of a particle prior to measuring it it's that the particle has no definite State
before it's measured for decades many thought this disagreement was a philosophical question that might never
be resolved after all in order to learn anything about a system we need to measure it how can we possibly learn
anything about the nature of a state prior to its measurement then in 1964 the physicist
John Bell found a way in his paper bell examined the statistical correlations between measurements of a pair of
entangled particles if prior to measurement the states of the particles were determined by some unknown hidden
variables then Bell found that their correlations had an upper limit on the other hand when he calculated the
correlations predicted by quantum mechanics he found that they violated this limit so he had found a way to once
and for all differentiate between Einstein and Bourne's view all that remained was to actually experimentally
test these correlations with real particles to see whether they obeyed the hidden variable statistics or they
violated that rule these tests were performed with increasing precision and sophistication
over the years and they're some of the most significant experiments of modern physics they were so groundbreaking that
they earned three physicists the Nobel Prize in 2022 but these days anyone can perform a
bell test all we need is a little knowledge of kcit and access to an IBM quantum computer in this video I'm going
to walk you through the logic of Bell's inequality then I'll show you how we can test Bell's predictions on an IBM
quantum computer Bell's inequality involves a few different measurements and layers of logic and it can be a
little tricky to follow but we'll go through it step by step and in the end it'll be worth it we're about to show
that entanglement is real and Einstein is wrong that's not something many people can say they've done so here's
what Belle proposed let's say you have a way to produce many copies of an entangled pair of particles physically
these pairs could be produced through a Decay process where one particle decays into two if you watch the video on the
stern gerlock experiment you know that particles can have an intrinsic angular momentum called
spin say one spin zero particle decays into two spin 1/2
particles then each of the spin 1/2 particles can be measured to have either spin plus2 or minus
one2 also called spin up or spin down but since they decayed from a spin zero particle then the two must combine to
have a total spin of zero also so if one is measured to be up the other must be
down and vice versa these particles form an entangled pair that looks like this
so if one is measured to be up the other one is down and vice versa let's say particle one flies off to the left or
the minus X Direction where a researcher who will call Lucas measures its
spin then particle two similarly flies off to the right
where another researcher Rihanna can measure that spin Lucas and Rihanna can independently
rotate their measurement devices to choose to measure the spin of their respective particles along any direction
perpendicular to the particle's direction of motion if we send many copies of the entangled state to Lucas
and Rihanna they can collect measurement statistics if they always measure along the same axis these statistics will not
be very interesting every time one measure spin up the other measure spin down and every time one measure spin
forward the other measure spin backward and so on but if the two researchers measure along different axes we may find
something more interesting let's give Lucas and Rihanna three axes along which to
measure we'll call these axes a b and c and they're each separated by
120° the question we will ask with this experiment is if Lucas and Rihanna are free to measure along any of the three
axes how often will the two obtain the same sign clearly if Lucas and ranum happen to measure along the same axis
say axis a they can never get the same sign since the particles must combine to have spin zero but when they pick
different axes how will their measurements be correlated if at all according to Einstein this quantum
mechanical description of the particle state is incomplete he thought there must exist hidden variables that
predetermine the outcome of all possible spin measurements since without that entangled particles would have to
somehow communicate the outcome of their measurement to one another instantaneously if one was measured to
be up way over here the other must instantaneously know to be down over
here these hidden variables could be any complicated set of instructions for the outcome of experiments but the point is
that the spin state of each particle separately is determined so no communication is necessary
experimentally that would mean that measurements made by Lucas would have no effect on Rihanna's particle and vice
versa this could put some limits on how correlated the two measurements can be according to Bourn though this state
sigh is all that can be said about the pair of particles prior to measurement so the measurement of one particle
affects the outcome of the measurement of the other this may have different implications for the correlations between measurements let's see how each
Theory affects these correlations in the hidden variables treatment there's a secret set of instructions prior to
measurement that already determines what Lucas will measure along each of the three axes for example these
instructions could be positive if Lucas measures along an axis a
positive if he measures along B and negative if he measures along c we can
write this as plus a plus b and minus C then Rihanna's particle
would need to have the variables minus a minus B and plus C to make sure that the total
spin along any single direction is zero
there are eight sets of possible instructions that satisfy this spin zero constraint so each time a new pair of
particles is sent to Lucas and Rihanna it could contain any one of these eight sets of instructions so now we want to
figure out assuming the particles contain one of the secret sets of instructions given in the table and
assuming that Lucas and Rihanna each independently choose which of the three axes to measure along what is the
probability that they both measure the same sign if the instructions are those given in rows 1 or
8 then clearly this probability is zero since the two particles will have the opposite signs regardless of their
measurement axes but what about the instructions in row two they would measure the same signs if
Rihanna measured along c and Lucas measured along either a or b or if Lucas
measured along c and Rihanna measured along either A or B so that's four out of nine of the
possible measurement combinations that will give Lucas and Rihanna the same sign if we do this for
each set of the instructions you'll see that Rows 3 through 7 also give a probability of 4 9ths this means that if
Einstein is right and hidden variables like these predetermine the outcome of measurements there's no way for Lucas
and Rihanna to ever measure the same sign with probability greater than 4 9th this is the Bell inequality P less than
or equal to 4 9ths and as we'll show entangled particles violate this so to
see what quantum mechanics predicts say Lucas measures long a two things can happen either he measures spin up so
Rihanna would measure spin down along a or he measures spin down and Rihanna would measure spin up along a but we
want the probability that Rihanna measures the same sign as Lucas along any axis of her choosing not just a if
she measures along either B or C it gets a little complicated it turns out that
if you know what Rihanna will measure with 100% certainty along One Direction then you can calculate the probabilities
that she will measure up or down along any other axis with a little geometry
if your state always measures spin up along one axis then the probability of measuring spin up along a different axis
will be equal to the square of the cosine of 1/2 of the angle between the two axes that's a little complicated but
I'll show you what I mean if Lucas measures spin up along a we know with 100% certainty Rihanna would measure
spin down if she were to measure a a so we can represent that with a vector VOR
like this in this case the angles between this vector and the other two measurement axes B and C are both
60° so 1 half of that is 30° and cosine of
30 is shown here cosine squar of
30° equal 34s now what if Lucas measures spin down
along a we know Rihanna would measure spin up along a so we can draw another Vector here now
this Vector representing this knowledge is 120° from each of the other two axes B
and C so we can do the same geometry trick but this time we'll get cosine of
60° so cosine squared of
60° equal 1/4 since Lucas is equally likely to
measure spin up and spin down along a we need to average these two probabilities of Rihanna we end up with a final
probability that Rihanna will measure the same sign as Lucas of 1 12 so P
equal 12 1/2 is bigger than 4 9ths so Bell's inequality is is violated
that means that as long as the rules of quantum mechanics hold hidden variables are impossible now we can use kcit and an
IBM quantum computer to test the Bella inequality with real Quantum measurements we can map the spin up and
spin down states of Lucas and Rihanna's particles to the zero and one states of the cubits in the quantum computer we'll
take two cubits one to represent Lucas's particle and one for Rihanna's and entangle them with this Quantum circuit
so the two cubits are represented by the two wires q0 and q1 and this combination
of X hadamard and c not Gates will make the same entangled State we had between Lucas and Rihanna's particles now we
need to measure each Cubit we'll set Lucas's measurement to be along a which we'll say is the Z axis then Rihanna's
measurement can be along a b or c so we'll need three separate circuits for each of these three cases but in this
video we'll just do one you can go to the module Linked In the description for the full thing if Rihanna measures along
B then our circuit looks like this where r y is a rotation of 120 de to change
Rihanna's measurement axis we can use the kcit Primitive sampler to run this experiment many times and collect
statistics from the resulting measurements the two columns 0 0 and 1 1 represent the times when Lucas and
Rihanna measured the same sign which is what we're after so the probability of measuring both particles to have the
same sign is very nearly 1/2 this violates Bell's inequality this means
that the two particles are entangled each one somehow seems to instantaneously know the results of a
measurement of the other there's still some disagreement about how exactly to interpret this
entanglement and what happens when you measure an Tangled state but these questions are more philosophical the
theory is pretty undeniable at this point entanglement is definitely real and we know this thanks to Bell his
inequality and the many physicists who have performed experiments to test it if you'd like to be counted among those
physicists and perform your own Bell test with a quantum computer be sure to head over to the bells inequality module
Linked In the description thanks for watching and I'll see you next time